be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so as we continue
our discussion on Batman in game what I
want to do here is start with a recap of
what we discuss in the last video and
they continue on with a battle between
Batman and Superman
so in the last video we had talked about
how Batman endgame came out of the
events of death of the family which
depicted the Joker is trying to kill
Batgirl and the various Robins but also
came out of Batman eternal during the
year-long eternal story from Scott
Snyder while it didn't involve the Joker
it did introduce a woman by the name of
Julia pennyworth who was the estranged
daughter of Alfred while future stories
may see an expansion on her character
within the confines of endgame her role
sees her working as an informant for
Batman while he's in the field but her
involvement also has a background theme
of tending to her father Alfred whom she
views as a failure due to becoming a
butler for the Wayne's now in terms of
our video on endgame as we discussed in
the eyes of the Joker Batman was a much
darker and more ruthless person prior to
taking on sidekicks and expanding on the
bat family but because he had partners
and incorporated other individuals into
his life who could aid him in taking
down various criminals and faced
overwhelming odds to the Joker this had
removed the cunning and dark edge from
Batman and instead of returning to his
roots as a do whatever it takes antihero
the Joker came to believe that Batman's
moral code had made him soft and an
effort to rectify this the Joker
implemented the events taking place
during death of the family as a way to
destroy the bat family's trust in Batman
and killed him if at all possible
while the story showed us that Batman
was successfully able to keep the bat
family alive the Joker's plan was
ultimately successful and that the rest
of the bat family lost their trust in
Bruce Wayne due to the fact that he had
kept important information from them in
the form of Joker having previously
accessed the Batcave and possibly
learning their identities and so with
the bad family remaining alive but
distrustful a Batman the beginning of
endgame saw Bruce Wayne attacked by the
Justice League in the form of Wonder
Woman the flash Aquaman and finally
Superman while he was until to hold his
own and incapacitate each one in turn at
the end of our video leading into
Batman's battle with Superman Bruce
Wayne had come to the revelation that
the Joker had hearted of the Justice
League in an effort to continue the
systematic destruction of Bruce Wayne's
allies by turning them against him
this will picking up within game what
Scott Snyder does here is directly
address the debate between Batman versus
Superman and the history of DC Comics
the battle of Batman and Superman is an
ageless question that splits fans down
the middle with each side staunchly
believe you that their son is right in
the comics the battle between the two
usually came down to Batman coming out
on top
due to his use of kryptonite what Snyder
does here is argue that while kryptonite
is a contributing factor to Batman's
constant defeats over Superman the
actual reason for his success is because
Superman always holds back while Snyder
doesn't necessarily address this
question in particular I would argue
that this is largely due to the respect
that exists between the two throughout
their publication histories while
alternate reality stories like injustice
and in continuity stories like hush saw
the two butting heads in the end despite
the scenario that brought the two into
conflict their respect for one another
always kept Superman from completely
destroying and killing Batman and in
turn allowed the two to mend the rift
that existed between them however in
this story with Superman operating under
the complete control of Joker's toxin
the respect Superman has for Batman does
not play a role and instead Superman is
governed by the overriding command from
the Joker to kill Batman as always
though the element of Kryptonite is
introduced and comes into play when
Batman spits a kryptonite laced polymer
into the eyes of Superman containing a
green kryptonite dust the polymer is
able to render Superman powerless and as
a result
Batman is able to take him along with
the rest of the Justice League back to
the Batcave in order to help them
recuperate and allow the toxin to run
its course
however the discussion between Batman
and Alfred as well as Julia raises an
extremely important problem as Batman
states the Justice League never operates
in a singular location except for the
most dire of circumstances due to the
fact that a situation just like this
could occur renewing almost all of them
incapacitated with Bruce Wayne as the
only member of the league with his full
faculties the question now becomes what
does he do if a worldwide crisis were to
occur furthermore the motives of the
Joker are revisited during Bruce's
discussion with Julia as he states it in
the eyes of the Joker he doesn't see
himself as a villain
instead the Joker sees himself as
someone who is witnessed Batman
succumbing to the weakness of dependency
by way of the Robin sidekicks and
Batgirl and that their physical
assistance and mental support have
stripped Batman of his ability to
operate without the aid of others now
something that I want to do here is I
want to wind the clock back to zero year
and Batman annual number two with zero
year focusing on Bruce Wayne's journey
to become Batman as well as this early
escapades as a Dark Knight and Batman
annual issue number two Scott Snyder
introduced a character named Eric
borders as a new employee in Arkham
Asylum
Eric was introduced to us as an idealist
who viewed Arkham as a place where the
criminally insane were largely left
neglected rather than being adequately
cared for as it was presented Eric was a
man who genuinely seemed to want to care
for the inmates at Arkham and so in his
eyes Arkham was a facility that served
as a beacon for hope for the mentally
insane rather than a dumping ground
looking to restore his former reputation
Eric looked to this facility as a way to
rehabilitate criminals in order to allow
them to be reintegrated into society
transitioning back to endgame batman
travels to Arkham Asylum
in an effort to search for clues that
may lead him to understanding what the
Joker's doing with the Justice League as
well as the greater plan that he most
likely has while he's there Batman
encounters Eric who had remained behind
due to his ties to his time in Arkham
Asylum in the mists of their
conversation and while Batman
investigates the Joker so Eric states
that when he first started working at
Arkham Asylum his goal was to help
inmates by rehabilitating them but at
the same time he also wanted to help
Batman now while this statement is
really only provided as a function of
their conversation the sidetrack here
for a second one of the most common
philosophical arguments on Batman is
that in truth because the death of his
parents drove him to become the Dark
Knight by way of donning a bat costume
that in all honesty Batman is most
likely as insane as the Arkham inmates
but because he stands as the hero of the
Batman title and because he serves
Gotham within the context of the story
the light that shines on his character
varies from the inmates and the Gotham
City turns a blind eye to his actions
and allows Batman to operate with near
impunity however in the midst of their
conversation Eric shuts the door on
Joker cell levy
Batman trapped inside and while Bruce
attempts to understand why he's doing
this
Eric stated his name is actually a false
one according to a combination of the
Norse language and Gothic tradition Eric
actually means eternal prince and border
is a now obsolete Shakespearean word
which means jester meaning that by
pairing the name using traditional name
organization Eric border translates into
jester the eternal prince revealing that
Eric borders is actually the Joker and
has been hiding in plain sight as an
employee of Arkham Asylum during the
events of court of owls and knight of
owls something I also hope you notice
here is that unlike his appearance in
death of the family the Joker has his
normal face while the question that fans
had is how this happened as far as I've
been able to tell there exists no answer
within the Batman comics and Scott
Snyder never addresses this in any
interviews however what the joke reveals
here is that his actions and death of
the family were aimed at helping Batman
to shed his weakness and in return take
him back to his darker role but when
Batman had dropped the Joker off a cliff
at the conclusion of death of the family
the Joker took this to mean that Batman
is beyond being helped and began
organizing the events of endgame as a
way to basically kill Batman releasing
his Joker toxin on the city of Gotham
The Joker states that his plan is to
devolve the city into a place of
complete madness and because Batman
cherishes Gotham above all else
the idea is to systematically torture
Batman by forcing him to witness the
destruction of Gotham at the hands of
its own citizens
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and in the
next video we're going to focus more on
the Joker as well as how Batman views
him and the events that lead up to the
final confrontation between the two with
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace